[Música]
el candidato izquierdista de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva lidera una nueva
encuesta frente al presidente Yair
bolsonarok pero con un margen más
estrecho de Cara a la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales el próximo
30 de octubre el actual mandatario
mantiene su discurso de negación contra
los sondeos
al menos tres muertos deja el
desbordamiento de un río en el estado de
aragua en Venezuela el presidente
Nicolás Maduro recorrió la zona afectada
en un hecho que ocurre apenas una semana
después de un deslizamiento de tierras
en el mismo estado Que dejó más de 50
víctimas mortales enlazamos con Caracas
el presidente peruano Pedro Castillo
intenta frenar la demanda constitucional
en su contra ante la Corte Suprema de
Justicia la defensa del mandatario
presentó un recurso para anular la
demanda impuesta en su contra por la
fiscalía ampliamos desde Lima
momento de actualizar las noticias aquí
en la pantalla de Franz 24 Mi nombre es
Juan pupiales gracias por estar con
nosotros y Estas son las noticias más
destacadas del continente americano Un
día después del primer debate entre los
dos candidatos presidenciales de Brasil
el actual mandatario Yahir evolucionario
y el izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva una nueva encuesta mantiene el
favoritismo de este último la
encuestadora ipec situado 7 puntos
porcentuales por debajo de Lula da Silva
el presidente ultraconservador más
arremetió contra las firmas de encuestas
y aseguró que están buscando ayudar a
Lula a obtener más votos Natalia plazas
nos cuenta los detalles
en la recta final para las elecciones en
Brasil el más reciente sondeo del
instituto IP continúa dando la ventaja
al ex presidente lulada Silva sobre el
actual mandatario Yair bolsonaro esta
encuesta situada izquierdista con un 50%
de la intención de Voto y prevé para su
rival un 43%. descartando los votos
nulos y en blanco establece un 54% del
apoyo para Lula y un 46% para bolsonaro
la encuesta sitúa a ambos candidatos dos
puntos más cerca que la anterior
realizada por el Instituto una semana
antes en un contexto en el que las
principales encuestadoras dan como
ganador a Lula da Silva bolsonaroa
arremetió hoy contra el ipec y otra de
las principales encuestadoras datafolia
datafolia es una vergüenza en 2018 decía
que si pasaba a segunda ronda perdería
con cualquiera y el ipec no acierta nada
pero influye en el voto en sus
declaraciones el ultraderechista pone el
dedo en la llaga en un tema sensible Y
es que las firmas de encuestas han sido
altamente seleccionadas tras sus
previsiones para la primera vuelta los
sondeos indicaban una ventaja de Lula de
hasta 15 puntos por encima del
ultraderechista el pasado 3 de octubre
un margen lejano a la realidad Pues
bolsonaro quedó solo a 5 puntos del
izquierdista el sondeo llega Solo un día
después del primer cara a cara
televisivo entre ambos candidatos antes
de las elecciones un debate marcado por
acusaciones mutuas de mantener amistades
con criminales también señalamientos a
Lula por la corrupción en el partido de
los trabajadores y a bolsonaro por la
gestión de la pandemia algunos de los
principales temas de una tensa campaña
plagada de acusaciones entre ambos
candidatos
Venezuela las lluvias siguen azotando el
estado aragua en el centro del país al
menos tres muertos deja el
desbordamiento de un río en la ciudad de
maracay el presidente Nicolás Maduro se
desplazó hasta la zona se trata de un
estado en el que un deslizamiento de
tierra ya dejó nueve fallecidos hace
apenas nueve días
desde Caracas los amplía nuestra
corresponsal Daniela Zambrano
al momento el reporte oficial es de tres
personas fallecidas tras el
desbordamiento del río castaño está
ubicado en maracay capital del Estado
aragua centro Norte del país el propio
Nicolás Maduro ha recorrido la zona y
hasta el momento no se ha podido
contabilizar los daños materiales las
autoridades se encuentran evacuando
algunas de las comunidades por temor a
otros desbordamientos recordemos que
Precisamente en el estado aragua el
pasado 8 de octubre pero en la zona de
tejerías ocurrió la tragedia que ha
dejado al momento a 54 personas
fallecidas y otras 56 desaparecidas de
hecho todavía se encuentran las labores
de búsqueda en la zona por supuesto sin
mayor esperanza de encontrar
sobrevivientes Nicolás Maduro se
encontraba en la zona de tejerías cuando
le fue anunciada este otro
desbordamiento de ríos y acudió a
recorrer la zona protección civil se
encuentra en el lugar y han evacuado
algunas de las poblaciones por temor el
desbordamiento de quebradas las lluvias
en los últimos semanas en Venezuela han
dejado fuertes destrozos principalmente
en los Estados zulia Lara y aragua
la defensa del presidente peruano Pedro
Castillo presentó un recurso ante la
Corte Suprema para anular la denuncia
que la fiscalía presentó contra el
mandatario por presuntamente encabezar
una organización criminal esto amenaza
con quitarle su inmunidad previamente
conectamos con nuestro corresponsal en
Lima Francisco Zacarías quien nos
explicó los argumentos de la defensa del
presidente para este recurso
Benji Espinoza abogado del presidente
Pedro Castillo afirma que la denuncia de
la fiscalía es inconstitucional porque
viola una resolución de la Corte Suprema
que establece que el mandatario
solamente puede estar acusado
constitucionalmente por el congreso
durante su gobierno por cuatro
cuestiones específicas que establece el
artículo 117 de la Constitución peruana
que son traición a la patria e impedir
la realización de las elecciones
disolver el congreso y bloquear a los
organismos electorales y por tanto sería
inconstitucional que tanto de la
fiscalía como el parlamento e impulsan
un proceso contra el mandatario por la
presunta comisión de los delitos de
organización criminal tráfico
influencias y colusión la defensa
también señala que se estaría
desconociendo a la Constitución peruana
y también
violando un mandato judicial
el embajador estadounidense en México
quien Salazar reiteró este lunes que los
migrantes venezolanos que ingresen a
Estados Unidos de forma irregular por
tierra para ser deportados a México esto
tras la nueva política migratoria
acordada entre ambas naciones Desde el
miércoles pasado que incluye la
recepción de 24.000 venezolanos que
arriben por vía aérea a la Unión
Americana y demuestren respaldo
económico una decisión que según
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos deja
en desventaja a las personas más
vulnerables
venezolanos que llegan a la frontera de
los Estados Unidos y México no pueden
entrar no van a poder entrar
se van a
regresar no se pueden decir que
estas
organizaciones criminales
transnacionales son no más de México son
de Estados Unidos o son de países en
Centroamérica ellos operan sin frontera
en Estados Unidos este lunes dieron
inicio las votaciones anticipadas de
Cara a las elecciones de medio término
en el estado de Georgia dado el
presidente de acoso a los funcionarios
electorales tras la derrota de los
republicanos de este bastión conservador
muchos trabajadores han decidido dejar
sus puestos además ambos candidatos al
senado de las dos bancadas están
envueltos en sendas polémicas
con un nuevo ciclo electoral de medio
término las miradas están nuevamente
enfocadas en Georgia un estado que fue
clave para la carrera por la casa blanca
y para darle a los demócratas un
estrecho control de la cámara alta con
un aura de temor entre los trabajadores
electorales por las amenazas que
sufrieron en 2020 tras las infundadas
acusaciones de su puesto fraude
electoral de Donald Trump tras su
derrota Joe biden ganó el que había sido
el bastión republicano desde 1992 ha
sido una lucha a conseguir trabajadores
electorales en todo Georgia muchas
personas debido a los últimos ciclos no
han querido serlo Vanesa fue una de las
trabajadoras acosada y sometida a la
presión política cada uno de sus
compañeros No han querido retomar sus
puestos en estos comicios ella no temo
volver
si permito que la gente mente mide así y
me quite algo que disfruto hacer ellos
tienen el poder sobre mí y si alguien
tiene poder sobre ti entonces creo que
puede hacerte cualquier cosa que quieran
lo hago para asegurarme de Que todos
tengan el derecho que tengan derecho a
votar puedan venir y hacerlo para
facilitarles el proceso para asegurarme
de que entiendan el proceso
la polémica envuelve también a los
principales candidatos en la carrera por
uno de los escaños en el senado el
conservador Walker es jugador de fútbol
americano y firme antiaportista está
acusado de haber pagado un aborto a una
de sus exparejas su rival el pastor
demócrata Rafael warnock también fue
acusado por su exmujer de violencia
machista ambos niegan las acusaciones
sabes es una elección de alto perfil
Creo que muchas de las afirmaciones del
último ciclo electoral han sido
desacreditadas así que tengo la
esperanza de que este sea un ciclo
electoral tranquilo Georgia podría
volver a tener las llaves para que los
demócratas mantengan el control del
senado en un estado donde las nuevas
leyes electorales apuntan a reducir la
participación de las minorías en el
proceso democrático el departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos pidió un juez
Federal que condene el asesor del ex
presidente Donald Trump Steve hace meses
de prisión por desacatón a las
situaciones del comité del Congreso que
Investiga el ataque al Capitolio del 6
de enero de 2021 vano que tiene 68 años
allá fue condenado en julio por dos
cargos de desacato al congreso por
desafiar una citación para aclarar su
versión de los acontecimientos cada
cargo se castiga con entre 30 días y un
año de prisión y una multa que puede
llegar hasta los 100 mil dólares la
decisión hace conocerá este viernes
así concluimos este Informativo quédense
en la pantalla de France 24
[Música]